here's a really interesting little clip
by the way from the right-wing media
machine around the Trump investigation
this is from Fox News yesterday even on
Fox News now
anchors are starting to concede that you
know what robert molars from prussia
investigation might actually have
something and before i play the clip
it's really important just to preface it
by reminding you about the goalposts
moving that's taken place right early on
Fox News was fully on the there's
nothing to investigate and no big
investigation is going to take place
that was the first position Fox took the
investigation started
they were then on the there's nothing to
find
there's no collusion this will go
nowhere and not last very long bandwagon
then they move the goalposts to okay if
there was collusion what crime is that
anyway that's not a specific crime then
they move to well okay there might
actually be some ancillary incidental
criminality by people loosely in Trump
circle but it's not going to have
anything to do with the real heart of
trumps campaign it'll be little
technicalities committed by people prior
to the campaign that wouldn't even be on
the radar of law enforcement were it not
for the political attack that is the
investigation into Donald Trump and then
we get back to reality and of course in
reality we're heading to sentencing for
Trump's national security adviser we're
heading to sentencing for Donald Trump's
personal lawyer who was directly
involved in the campaign we're heading
to sentencing for Donald Trump's
campaign chairman I'm talking by the way
about Michael Flynn Michael Cohen and
Paul Manafort and then we also have
lurking in the background
Roger stone and Jerome Corsi to Trump
operatives during the campaign who
believe they're going to be indicted and
are negotiating with Robert Muller and
it's looking really really bad it also
by the way appears that Donald Trump's
written answers to Robert Muller might
directly contradict what Michael Cohen a
cooperating witness has said to Robert
Muller that Donald Trump juniors
testimony
might directly contradict what michael
cohen told prosecutors so it's getting
really bad and perjury lying under oath
is now on the table for multiple Trump
family members so now we cut to
yesterday even on Fox News they're
starting to admit it check out this clip
where they have this right-wing or match
slap on who continues to insist that
there's just nothing here and one of the
hosts who goes by Kennedy says it's
starting to get a little weird and
Muller might actually have something
there's that but I say something very
quickly put a pin in it Kennedy there
might be something there
they're absolutely might be something
there we don't know what more has he
might something he might have something
things are starting to seem a little
weird you know what else he might have
he might have something on the dossier I
hope he does if they're if they're
putting one aspect of filthy dirty
disgusting politics cavorting with
questionable Russians on one side they
have to do it on the other but there
might be something there
we will stay tuned we will see hopefully
soon so you'll notice that she kind of
does the both sides thing she says okay
Mulder might have something but he also
might have something on that dirty
filthy immoral dossier more and more of
which by the way is confirmed with every
passing week the other funny thing is
that this obvious and straightforward
admission on Fox News is considered
mind-blowing to their audience everybody
and their mother who can put together a
sentence understands that hey this has
been serious all along this hasn't been
frivolous all along on Fox News Pat it's
almost like oh wow they're admitting
that the entire investigation might not
be a ruse like there might actually be
something here on Fox News that counts
as an ammonia mental admission there are
also like many conspiratorial elements
that statement to it sounds like the q
on on stuff that Robert Muller maybe as
actually working with Trump and he's
going to end up in died ting Hillary
Clinton in John Podesta there's no
evidence of that
but I think that conspiratorial nature
is becoming part and parcel with the
Republican Party nowadays well let me
propose along those lines one other idea
this isn't conspiratorial but it's sort
of the idea that's starting to concede
that this is a real serious
investigation as part of
strategy because we saw rudy giuliani
say a couple of weeks ago I think molars
report will be devastating to Trump
Kennedy saying you know there this could
be bad this could be a strategy to start
painting a really grim picture so that
then when molars report finally does
come out they all go oh this is all they
had we've been saying for so long now
that it's going to be really bad but
this is all they had give me a break
one other note later in the segment that
matched lap guy said molar has no case
and that all molar is doing his quote
taking the dirt he's gotten on people
like Cohen and squeezing them to get
everything he can out of them that's
what an investigation is that's what law
enforcement does they talk to witnesses
they learn more about what people did
and they figure out who else to talk to
and who might have committed crimes like
mad slap defends Trump by just saying
what an investigation is apparently on
Fox News that counts as a serious legal
defense of the president and an
indictment of the investigation they're
talking to witnesses and using the
information they get to make deductions
and find more people to talk to send me
your thoughts the show is on Instagram
at David Pakman show I'm on instagram at
david dot Pakman follow us both lotta
behind-the-scenes pictures viewer
comments a lot of good stuff on there
today's program is sponsored in part by
Blink accom slash Pakman if you've not
already heard about blink Asst
it's amazing it's an app for your phone
tablet or web browser and what they do
is they take nonfiction books popular
nonfiction critically acclaimed
nonfiction they condense the book into a
fifteen minute audio book you get all
the most important information and
insights from each book but you can soak
up the entire essence of the book in one
sitting I've listened to a ton of books
on blinkin recent one is a Robert Rice's
new book the common good
also bunk by Kevin Young useful in
preparing
for the pseudoscience miniseries that
we're producing and if you are a david
pakman show viewer or listener you can
get a seven day free trial by going to
blink accom slash Pakman if you're
watching on youtube use the link in the
video description
after the free trial if you like it you
can get the full access to thousands of
condensed audiobooks for about five
bucks a month that's be li NK is t.com
/pa ke ma n